[Music]
thank you
one of the key themes running throughout
the entirety of Ursula Kayla Green's
story dragonfly is that character
attempting to figure out who and what
she truly is now in the Queen's world of
Earthsea this is very much tied to the
notion of a name specifically a true
name and we see this arising when
dragonfly is going to be named by the
village which rose and they have a
conversation prior to this Rose tells
dragonfly who she's going to name Erie
and that she has a certain strength in
her but it's mysterious
she is going to tell her that she's got
here it is you have a strengthen you a
great one and you know it too what you
are to do I don't know nor do you that's
to find but there's no such power as to
name yourself and so Rose is going to
name dragonfly she gives her the name
erian which dragonfly feels is kind of a
betrayal and we've talked about that
elsewhere and when she does that there's
a very important line here
so she's dragonfly is confronting Rose
and Rose says I spoke your true name
it's not what I thought it would be and
I don't feel easy about it
as if I'd left something unfinished but
it is your name if it betrays you then
that's the truth of it so it's right but
it's also not right there's a surplus
there there's a there's a more that
isn't being
made manifest although it is being you
could say acknowledged in its hidden
existence and then when we move ahead to
the third section of it where irian now
named is speaking with the Dorman one of
the Masters of Rogue the one who guards
the door where she has to give her name
as the password he asked her do you know
whose name you must tell me before I let
you in and she says my own sir it is
irian and he says is it that gave her
pause
she stood silent
it's the name the witch Rose of my
Village on way gave me in the spring
under area Hill she said at last
standing up and speaking truth
the door keeper looked at her for what
seemed like a long time
then it is your name he said but maybe
not
all your name I think you have another
I don't know it sir
after a long time she said maybe I can
learn it here sir
and this is when the door keeper bows
his head makes a very faint smile and
says come in daughter and she steps
Across the Threshold into the great
house precipitating the crisis that is
going to occupy the last two parts of
the work
so the idea here is that you know once
again following up on Rose naming her
there's something more going on here
there's something that hasn't been
brought completely to light and so maybe
she can learn this name here at roke if
there's any place where it would be
possible Maybe This Is It
and when we have this discussion going
on between the different people we have
um the neighbor himself
actually you know saying that maybe
there's more to the story than what is
going on uh the Namer actually gives her
his name and he says is the master name
or here I make free with names my own
included who named you irian and she
says the witch Rose of our village Lord
and then the doorkeeper says is she
misnamed so they're going to try to
figure this out
uh the Namer says no
but and there's a very pregnant but
there right
then uh when she goes to the imminent
Grove with the patterner
she is going to you know be asked does
she actually have any knowledge did Rose
teach her and there's a lot of
misunderstandings about this among the
Masters isn't there so
he says you've been a witch erian and
she says no
but you have some knowledge no I don't
Rose wouldn't teach me she said she
didn't dare because I had power but she
didn't know what it was
your rose is a wise flower said the mage
unsmiling
but I know I have something to do
something to be that's why I wanted to
come here to find out on the aisle of
the wise she was getting used to a
strange face now and was able to read it
she thought that he looked sad his way
of speaking was harsh dry quick
Peaceable the men of the aisle are not
always wise eh maybe the doorkeeper he
looked at her now not glancing but
squarely his eyes catching and holding
hers but they are in the wood under the
trees there is the old wisdom I can take
you into the Grove and there's hopes
that in the Grove perhaps she can she
can figure out what she is what maybe
this mystery of her name can come to
light and this is when you know she
lives there for a while and then things
come to a head and as the conflict is
about to
stem into its its final stage
there's an interesting exchange between
the two of those
she asks them as for the patterner why
did you break your rule for me was it
fair to me who can never be what you are
as we're frowned the door keeper
admitted you because you asked I brought
you to the Grove because the leaves of
the trees spoke your name to me before
you ever came here irian they said irian
why you came I don't know but not by
Chance the Summoner too knows that and
so she suggests maybe I came to destroy
him he looked at her and said nothing
and then she says something else
maybe I came to destroy Rogue
his pale eyes blazed and try he
challenges her right and what is
revealed in this a long shudder went
through her as she stood facing him she
felt herself larger than he was larger
than she was enormously larger so
there's this sort of Revelation to her
an awareness of not only her own
strength
and I was going to say greatness but it
the green talks about largeness here so
perhaps that's the word that we ought to
be using
she could reach out one finger and
destroy him she stood there in his he
stood there in his small Brave brief
Humanity his mortality defenseless she
drew a long long breath she stepped back
from him the sense of huge strength was
draining out of her she turned her head
a little and looked down surprised to
see her Brown arm her rolled up sleeve
the grass springing cool and green
around her sandal feet she looked back
at the pattern he still seemed a fragile
being she pitied and honored him she
wanted to warn him of the Peril he was
in but no words came to her
she's finding out what she actually is
which will find we'll find out as
readers in the fourth part of the story
and just to prefigure a little bit the
kind of being that she is
humans would indeed appear as Le guine
says
um Brave brief Humanity mortality
defenseless by comparison to what she is
in her being then there's this
confrontation with thorian the Summoner
and you know if if all she was was a
human being then thorian would have had
the complete advantage over her he's not
only the strongest of all of the Mages
one who could be indeed archmage one who
came back from Death itself
but he also has her true name and he
uses it the Summoner looked up at irian
slowly he raised his arms and the White
staff and invocation of the spell
speaking in the tongue that all the
Wizards and mages of Rogue had learned
the language of their art the language
of the making Aryan by your name I
summon you and bind you to obey me
and then
she Springs on him and everybody else
something else she hesitated seeming for
a moment to yield to come to him and
then cried out I am not only erian this
Surplus this hidden other name is now
becoming something important and it
keeps him from being able to control her
he tries to attack and then we find out
she towered above him and possibly fire
breaking forth between him a flare of
red flame in the dusk air a gleam of Red
Gold scales of vast Wings then that was
gone
and there was nothing but the woman
standing on the hill path
and The Tall Man bowing down before her
bowing down slowly to the Earth and
lying on it
and when they go to see what's there
under the Huddle of the gray cloak The
herbal found in only a huddle of clothes
and dry bones and a broken staff so the
old Neighbor comes out and says who are
you
and irian says I do not know my other
name she spoke as she'd spoken as she'd
spoken to the Summoner in the language
of the making
the tongue the dragons speak
so she is indeed a dragon a dragon who
was born as a human being which does
happen in Earth sea and they discover
this at moments of Crisis this is what
has been there the entire time the great
strength that erian had from the
beginning that Rose could dimly
recognize that the doorkeeper perhaps
could recognize as well she now knows
that but
she still doesn't fully know herself her
name
so
she is going to go and find out what her
name is she says those who will give me
my name and fire not water my people and
then the patterner says in the west she
says beyond the West she turned away
from him and then went up the hill in
the Gathering Darkness as she went
farther from them they saw her all of
them the great gold mailed flanks the
spiking coiling tail the talons the
breath that was bright fire on the crest
of the Knoll she paused a while her long
head turning to look slowly around the
Isle of Rogue gazing longest at the
Grove only a blur of darkness in
darkness now then with a rattle like the
shaking of sheets of brass the wide vein
Wings opened and the dragon spring up
into the air circled Rogue Knoll once
more and flew
and that is the departure but before
that
something important does happen that we
should close in
irian said ozra the patterner
will you come back to us
she halted and let him come up to her I
will if you call me she said
and this indeed is going to happen those
two are going to have this ongoing
connection through that and so irian has
discovered what her place is it's not on
way it's not at Rogue it is indeed with
her people beyond the West
the dragons where she is going to be
welcomed and find out as orm Aryan who
she truly is and then she will come back
in the final book of Earthsea and play a
very significant role in the resolution
of the great crisis that faces not only
Rogue but all of Earthsea humans and
Dragons alike